hey Siri hey Siri hey Siri a serious
Siri I'm sorry I didn't quite catch that
do you know where I put my car keys
sorry I'm having trouble with our
connection please try again in a moment
so how do I look
I'd rather not say Siri find me
directions story didn't find me
directions find me what I what what no
no no can you run the numbers on that
report you have no real friends what do
I have any parties to go to this weekend
here's what I found on the web for to
have any parties to go to this weekend
no do I have any parties on my calendar
your calendar is as empty as my cold
dark soul text mom I love you and I miss
you here's your message for your bath
Ron I love you and I want to have sex
with you would you like me to send no no
no not Ron a mom send it's a mom okay
sending - mom I love you when I want to
have sex with you mmm no no delete sorry
delete I already sent that fool you
fired serious so incompetent oh that
doesn't sound good - Siri well I'm still
here for you I don't want you to be here
for me okay no wait don't leave open
Instagram I want to see Instagram Siri I
love you Siri you are the wind beneath
my wings
what get it there my god
yeah you get it it's here Quinta